Speaker 1: Southwest Airlines had this massive
meltdown, operational meltdown, flights canceled,
baggage lost, people stranded at airports,
in some cases arrested, simply trying to get
rebooked.
And Fox News had a segment during which they
tried to blame the secretary of transportation
in the Biden administration.
Pete Boudette.
Judge, it's absolutely ridiculous.
Richard Fowler, who I know a little bit, was
on this panel along with Titus or Tyrus and
some other people, a number of different experts,
as you can imagine.
And he said it's completely absurd to blame
Mayor Pete.
Let's take a listen to this discussion.
Speaker 2: Meantime, just sleeping at an airport
for anyone who's ever done it.
Not a good time.
So I just it's such a great way out there.
We have paid for so many flights and bloodstreams
for illegals throughout this.
Excellent point, Tyrus.
Richard, I'm going to ask you since your question
and I and I'm not saying this to be out.
No, no, no, no, no.
But I'm asking, are Democrats Democrats a
lot of hope and people in charge?
Are they embarrassed of just how he's performed
over the last couple of years?
This is not even about people to judge, though.
Let's be very clear.
This is already I wrong.
Hold on.
90% of the flights have been canceled in the
United States is from one airline.
A majority of the flights canceled around
the world is from one airline.
So to sit here is to blame this on the transportation
secretary.
When you have one airline and one air response,
not even the employees of this airline.
It's absurd.
Now, we don't have 90% of the flight.
Did not interrupt you.
I'm answering what he said, but I wouldn't
do it.
90% of the airline.
90% of flights cancel United States today
are from Southwest Airlines because you have
a bad management.
You have a they have bad software.
You can't blame the flight attendants.
You can't blame the pilots.
You can't blame the ramp agents.
You have to blame the people who sit in the
corporate suites of Southwest Airlines for
canceling flight period.
End of story.
To blame the border jet for the fact that
Southwest can't manage their planes is ridiculous.
You can blame me for that, but you could see
the response.
But could that could they.
Could they get busses just like they do for
legal?
This is.
Speaker 1: So crazy.
Speaker 2: People.
I mean.
I mean, sure.
But once again, this is this is about capitalism
and an airline that cannot manage it.
Don't fly Southwest Airlines.
All right.
Good point.
Up next, liberal airports are okay.
Speaker 1: So is anybody else noticing how
these small government conservatives all of
a sudden become socialists when a private
company is failing and saying, hey, the people
we've been accusing of being socialists for
years, the Biden administration, they're not
being socialist enough or even communist and
just managing what this private company is
doing.
So the real reason that this meltdown took
place was the Southwest Airlines internal
management system got completely overwhelmed.
They have a complicated model for assigning
flights.
They have an antiquated internal system for
managing and staffing those trips.
And company officials and union leaders and
experts are all in agreement about that.
First and foremost, the secretary of transportation
oversees the entire transportation sector.
So that includes aviation, maritime, transportation,
highways, rail, and they have other things
that they do as well.
It's a big picture position.
The Department of Transportation and BU the
judge as the secretary of transportation.
The idea that it's Buddha judges fault that
one airline had a massive meltdown because
of their own antiquated system or to try to
hold people to judge responsible, it's completely
and totally pathetic.
Now, let's go beyond that, because you could
say, well, the context in which this happened
is the responsibility of the Department of
Transportation or something up.
Just about all of the things that affect individual
airlines actually have nothing to do with
the Department of Transportation.
You've got weather weather's like a category
that affects flights, maintenance issues,
deferred maintenance, stacking up and accumulating
and creating a problem.
Staffing shortages.
Employees getting sick, for example, as we
saw during the COVID pandemic.
Technical problems.
It has nothing to do with the secretary of
Transportation at all.
Now, if you had some new.
Schmidt decree that limited the ability of
airlines to, I don't know, do whatever it
is they need to do.
And you could specifically point to it as
a policy affecting all airlines.
I would listen, there's no doubt about it.
But this is this is absolutely and completely
absurd.
P bu to judge is not an operational manager.
The secretary of transportation has nothing
to do with the internal dynamics of airlines
and doesn't influence day to day operations
in any way.
And this is just an attempt to criticize Joe
Biden's administration that that's really
all it is.
But maybe even more interesting is the hypocrisy
here.
This Republican Party, these right wingers
on Fox, very low information republic.
I mean, they go for the lowest hanging fruit
because that's what their audience expects.
The Republican Party has long espoused the
belief that government regulation is unnecessary
and it's bad for business.
Too much involvement from the government is
bad.
It's not that it's neutral.
It's actually bad.
We should leave the private sector to operate
without interference.
In this case, they immediately say it must
be the federal government's fault.
We should blame a judge because of the operational
delays of one airline, even despite all of
the complex factors that are that are involved
there.
It's absurd.
And they are pathetic and understand that
that segment we just watched.
They are calling for government intervention.
When they say Pete should have done more,
what they're saying is the government should
have gotten more involved in the operations
of a single private airline.
That's the opposite of what they normally
espouse.
So the hypocrisy is galling and it shouldn't
really surprise us because they're more interested
in scoring political points, particularly
with their audience, who seems to have barely
a clue what's going on.
I mean, this is not my opinion.
I'm not editorializing.
You look at studies that look at how informed
are people who primarily get their news from
outlet ABCD.
The people who primarily get news from Fox
are of the least informed people in one study.
People who get their news from Fox are less
informed than people who don't even pay attention
to the news, if you can believe that.
It's unbelievable.
That's who this message is tailored to.
Which ignores completely that they are calling
for the very thing which they claim to oppose
federal government getting involved in the
business of private industry.
We'll have this clip on our Instagram.
If you want to see it in its full glory, you
can find it by searching Instagram for a David
Pakman show.
You can also find me on Instagram by searching
for David Pakman